♪ ♪
- Hi, I'm Jason.
Welcome to Lubbock, Texas.
Let me give you a tour
of my shop.
I've got a treadle hammer
that's foot-powered,
like that, see?
Also have
a spring helve power hammer
that I spent
the last month building.
This will be its maiden voyage.
I hope it goes.
Come on in.
♪ ♪
Inside my shop, I've got
my main knife-making tools--
belt grinder, drill press,
heat-treat oven,
and a band saw.
- Today we're gonna do
something a little different.
We're gonna do a mini segment
called "Fire It Up"
with your host, Spicy Mike.
Today we're gonna make a sauce
that resembles exactly
what I tasted in round one.
So we're gonna use habañeros
as our spice,
and we're gonna use bananas to
make Will's fiery nanner sauce.
So we're gonna go--at least try
to shoot for a 50/50 mix
of habañeros and bananas.
So now that we have our
ingredients in the blender,
it's gonna take a liquid to
kind of pull it all together,
so we're gonna add a little bit
of apple cider vinegar.
So now we're gonna puree it.
[blender whirring]
- I've been in Texas
my whole life.
My family's been here
since the 1850s,
and so I try to incorporate
Texas history
into my knife work.
One of the things I like to do
in my knife work
is use historical
Texas materials.
For example, I've got some wood
that came from the grounds
of the Texas capitol.
I've got a wrought-iron
wagon-wheel rim
that belonged
to my great-great-grandfather
who lived in Spicewood, Texas.
And I've got a piece of
railroad rail
that's made of wrought iron.
This is from the first railroad
that ever went into Dallas
in 1872.
My knife making is really
about taking materials,
whether it's a historical story
or just a bar of metal,
and making something tangible
out of it.
That's what drives me
in this work.
So that's the basic shop tour.
I'm glad to have you along
with me this week.
- All right, so just to tie
everything together
just a little bit better,
because both habañeros
and bananas are a little sweet,
we're gonna add
just a little bit of honey.
Don't want to get crazy with it
because they're both
already sweet,
but honey does add a little bit
of extra flavor to it.
Now, you can eat it right now
if you want to.
It's totally ready to eat.
But if you want to put it
in a jar, leave the lid loose,
and set it in a warm area--
not very sunny,
just kind of in a warm area--
and let it ferment
for about five to six days,
it'll taste a whole lot better.
This Will's fiery nanner sauce.
Cheers, Will.
♪ ♪
It's really good.
That's really good.